15 seconds on the clock as well that's
just allowing the rook to take the pawn
i mean it's just crazy it's difficult
maybe
by process of elimination
who finds it you know shakarao is an
amazing tactical player okay so that
bishop was recaptured if black actually
took the pawn and gave check white's
king would have moved out the way we
would have seen white's queen disappear
but white would have had a rook a bishop
and some pawns and white would have
actually been close to winning there so
ironian
wow the king going forward again
this king has been on an adventure there
and back again just
okay it feels like it must be checkmate
soon but okay but where is it
and okay only one move
delivers the knockout blower okay and
it's actually
that's a check king
okay another check the king
wherever it goes now if it goes to the g
line the black rook is going to check it
if it goes back to e3 the black queen is
going to take a pawn with check so now
this feels yeah it's game over okay and
now that group will come down check
and it's actually checkmate next move um
at the very least the black can just
take the white queen and that skewer
that check forces mamadira to resign wow
and that means
the bonneroni and he is the winner of
this game and also the first
quarterfinal match against chakrid